el cristalino del ojo está compuesto
principalmente por agua y proteínas a
medida que envejecemos estas proteínas
pueden comenzar a agruparse y opacar el
cristalino esta opacificación se
denomina catarata la cirugía de
cataratas consiste en extirpar el
cristalino afectado del ojo e insertar
una lente artificial
antes de la cirugía se le aplicarán
gotas para dilatar la pupila y se
limpiará el área periocular
en muchos casos se aplicará anestesia
local alrededor del ojo o detrás de éste
es posible que se le ofrezca algún
sedante para que lo ayude a relajarse la
mayoría de las cirugías de cataratas
llevan menos de una hora
el método más común para extirpar las
cataratas es la facoemulsificación en
este procedimiento el cirujano observa a
través de un microscopio quirúrgico y
realiza tres pequeñas incisiones de
menos de 254 centímetros de largo en la
córnea o cerca de ella se realiza un
orificio a través de la cápsula del
cristalino y se utiliza una sonda
ecográfica para romper el cristalino o
pacificado en pequeños fragmentos estos
fragmentos se aspiran a través de las
incisiones luego se inserta una lente
artificial intraocular
las lentes intraoculares de plástico
silicona o acrílico no tienen partes
móviles y duran de por vida
debido a que las incisiones son muy
pequeñas por lo general no se necesitan
puntos la visión a menudo mejora
notablemente en forma inmediata después
de la cirugía otro método para extirpar
las cataratas es la denominada técnica
extracapsular en este procedimiento la
incisión que se realiza cerca de la
córnea es lo suficientemente grande como
para extraer la catarata de una sola
pieza al igual que en el procedimiento
anterior se inserta la lente artificial
para reemplazar la lente o cristalino
natural por lo general la recuperación
para este tipo de cirugía de cataratas
es más lenta debido a que la incisión es
mayor este procedimiento requiere puntos
sin embargo pocas veces es necesario
retirar los puntos
después de la operación generalmente se
le colocará un parche en el ojo y se lo
tendrán observación durante un corto
periodo para asegurarse de que no se
presenten ningún problema como por
ejemplo hemorragia la cirugía de
cataratas es un procedimiento
ambulatorio y la mayoría de los
pacientes son dados de alta el mismo día
sin embargo dado que la exposición a la
luz brillante al principio puede
resultarle incómoda no debería
arriesgarse a conducir un vehículo
inmediatamente después del procedimiento
deberá arreglar previamente que otra
persona lo lleve a su hogar